now russian-appointed officials in her
son and Crimea say Ukrainian missile has
hit a bridge connecting the two regions
so the chongar bridge is known as the
gate to Crimea that Russia annexed in
2014. crimea's Governor says the bridge
was struck by a Storm Shadow missile
we'll bring in Ali Hashem he's joining
us now from mariopo what more can you
tell us about the strike on the bridge
Ali
this bridge and another two Bridges
around it are vital routes from her son
towards the Crimean Peninsula and uh
and it's been used also for as a Supply
route for the Army and for normal people
who
go from from the first side to the
second side this was this was before
before the what the Russians call the
Special Operation this was the Border
point between Ukraine and Russia and
um the the uh the targeting of this
bridge today as per the Russian
officials might have also affected
another bridge now there is no
clarification in this regard but one of
the Russian officials who posted on
telegram about the news of The Hitting
of the the the bridge said that Bridges
were affected now we know that there are
three Bridges there and this is the
shortest way from Herson towards Crimea
it's also the shortest way from Ukraine
towards dunietsk and maripole the cities
of Dunya maripo so this is the
importance of of this bridge and the the
main issue now is that the the Russians
have decided as we understood to divert
The Roots towards uh other uh other ways
in order to repair the bridge after it's
uh being affected by the by the strike
and what's the significance of the type
of weapon that was used in the strike
foreign
well over the past few days the Russian
officials mainly the Russian defense
minister has warned that the ukrainians
are preparing for an attack with the uh
the shadow storm missile or another
American missile on uh Crimea and the
defense minister Sergey schweigo warned
that this is going to lead to a Russian
retaliation by hitting a Ukrainian
decision-making centers and but at the
same time this is going to involve the
the implicate the the UK and the us and
this war now we don't know how this is
going to uh have its its impact on the
war what what we know it is that this is
part and it's in the context of the
counter-offensive the ukrainians have
been uh have been launching since since
days and it's also affected and it could
affect a possible Russian of offensive
that could be in preparation in in
response to the counter offensive okay
thank you so much Ali Hashem reporting
from Mario Paul